tragisches ende eines idyllischen
ausflugs mit einem heißluftballon in
rheinland pfalz bei der landung rund 45
kilometer südlich von koblenz wurde ein
heißluftballon mit sieben insassen von
einem windstoß erfasst
der korb schlug mehrfach auf einem acker
auf vier der insassen wurden dabei aus
dem korb geschleudert
der ballon wurde dann den berg hinab
richtung rhein geschleift verfingen sich
schließlich in bäumen
dort wurden die restlichen drei insassen
gefunden
der ballonführer kam ums leben zwei
schwer verletzt zu sein nach angaben der
rettungskräfte
außer lebensgefahr an der rettungsaktion
waren mehr als 100 helfer beteiligt und
am unglücksort jetzt bild reporter jon
roth schon sagt uns gibt es mittlerweile
schon hintergründe zu diesem unglück wie
es dazu kommen konnte
also wie ich erfahren konnte hat der
ballonfahrer versuch den usa was
eigentlich hinter dem hügel der mir
liegt versucht auf einem bereits
gemähten acker ordnungsgemäß zu landen
dabei hat ihn offenbar eine ganz starke
windböe erwischt die wohl die luft aus
dem ballon gedrückt hat eine zeugin die
ich gefunden habe sagte mir dazu sie
haben es leider ganz genau mit ansehen
müssen
die höhe habe mit aller gewalt in bonn
getroffen
dieser sei eingeknickt der ballonführer
habe den brenner angeschaltet und sowie
gas so viel heiße luft wie nur irgend
möglich in die leer werdende öl gepumpt
aber es hat nicht mehr gelangt der
ballonflug auf vier personen das waren
drei ehepaare 42 69 jahre
zwei aus der region und zwei aus drei
und eine ehepaar aus nrw also zwei paare
wurden herausgeschleudert dann ist der
ballon hangabwärts gefallen oder
geschleift worden regelrecht er ist dann
hinter mir war sie wenn man das sieht
diesen blauen flecken ist hinter mir und
2 200 meter etwa oberhalb mehr zum
liegen gekommen dort wurden weitere bei
zwei weitere schwerverletzte geborgen
und der ballonführer aus neu und alt
es gibt im moment ein wahnsinniges
problem wie der ballon zu bergen ist hat
beuter hat es gestern abend bereits mit
einer 100 bis 150 meter langen seil
probiert dabei hat man eben die zwei
schwerverletzten bergen können wieder
ballon geborgen werden soll ist ja sehr
fraglich man hat schon einen
hubschrauber gedacht das ist illusorisch
weil einfach durch die hanglage kann ja
selber auch von einem windböe erwischt
werden und dabei verunfallt man überlegt
im moment ob man das eventuell mit einem
sehr sehr großen langen kran macht aber
das ist alles noch etwas utopie denn die
unfallstelle ist von der
staatsanwaltschaft noch nicht
freigegeben wie zu erfahren ist gibt es
seinen bereits informationen dazu wie es
den verletzten geht also nicht
öffentlich also mir hat noch keiner was
dazu erzählt ich kann darüber zurzeit
noch nicht sagen